Determine the number of
solutions to the quadratic
equation, x squared plus 14x
plus 49 is equal to 0.
There's a bunch of ways
we could do it.
We could factor it and just
figure out the values of x
that satisfy it and
just count them.
That will be the number
of solutions.
We could just apply the
quadratic formula.
But what I want to do here is
actually explore the quadratic
formula, and think about how we
can determine the number of
solutions without even maybe
necessarily finding them
explicitly.
So the quadratic formula tells
us that if we have an equation
of the form ax squared plus bx
plus c is equal to 0, that the
solutions are going to be-- or
the solution if it exists is
going to be-- negative b plus or
minus the square root of b
squared minus 4ac.
All of that over 2a.
Now the reason why this can be
2 solutions is that we have a
plus or minus here.
If this b squared minus 4ac is
a positive number-- so let's
think about this a little bit.
If b squared minus 4ac
is greater than 0,
what's going to happen?
Well, then it's a
positive number.
It's going to have
a square root.
And then when you add it to
negative b you're going to get
one value for the numerator, and
when you subtract it from
negative b you are going
to get another
value in the numerator.
So this is going to lead
to two solutions.
Now what happens if b squared
minus 4ac is equal to 0?
If this expression under the
radical is equal to 0, you're
just going to have the
square root of 0.
So it's going to be negative
b plus or minus 0.
And it doesn't matter whether
you add or subtract 0, you're
going to get the same value.
So in that situation, the
actual solution of the
equation is going to be
negative b over 2a.
There's not going to be this
plus or minus, it's not going
to be relevant.
You're only going to
have one solution.
So if b squared minus 4ac
is equal to 0, you
only have one solution.
And then what happens if
b squared minus 4ac
is less than 0?
Well if b squared minus 4ac is
less than 0, this is going to
be a negative number right here
and you're going to have
to take the square root
of a negative number.
And we know, from dealing with
real numbers, you can't take
the square root.
There is no real number
squared that becomes a
negative number.
So in this situation there is
no solutions, or no real--
when I say real I literally
mean a real
number-- no real solution.
So let's think about it
in the context of this
equation right here.
And just in case you're curious
if whether this
expression right here,
b squared minus 4ac,
has a name, it does.
It's called the discriminant.
This is the discriminant.
That's that part of the
quadratic equation.
It determines the number
of solutions we have.
So if we want to figure out the
number of solutions for
this equation, we don't have
to go through the whole
quadratic equation, although
it's not that much work.
We just have to evaluate
b squared minus 4ac.
So what is b squared
minus 4ac?
So b is right here, it's 14.
So it's 14 squared minus 4 times
a, which is 1, times c,
which is 49.
That c, right there, times 49.
What's 14 times 14?
Let me do it over here.
14 times 14.
4 times 4 is 16.
4 times 1 is 4.
Plus 1 is 56.
Put a 0.
1 times 14 is 14.
It is 6, 9, 1.
It's 196.
So this right here is 196.
And we can ignore the 1.
What's 4 times 49?
So 49 times 4.
4 times 9 is 36.
4 times 4 is 16 plus
3 is 190-- or is
19, so you get 196.
So this right here is 196.
So b squared minus 4ac
is 196 minus 196.
So 196 minus 196
is equal to 0.
So we're dealing with a
situation where the
discriminant is equal to 0.
We only have one solution.
And if you want, you could try
to find that one solution.
This whole part is going to
be the square root of 0.
It's just going to be 0.
So the solution is going to
be negative b over 2a.
And negative b is-- we
could just solve it.
Negative b is negative 14 over 2
times a. a is just 1 over 2.
So it's equal to negative 7.
That's the only solution
to this equation.
But if you just wanted to know
how many solutions, you just
have to find out that b squared
minus 4ac is 0.
So it's only going to
have one solution.
And there's other ways.
You could have actually factored
this pretty easily
into x plus 7 times x plus 7
and gotten the same result.